this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
J entrepreneurial thought leader lecture
series and has brought you every single
week by the Stanford Technology Ventures
program and by basis the Business
Association of Stanford entrepreneurial
students it is generously underwritten
by draper fisher Jurvetson and it's
brought you every week online by both
the Stanford center for professional
moment and by the Stanford Technology
Ventures program you can find it online
anywhere in the world at a corner dot
stanford.edu
our special guest today is olivia fox a
few months ago someone gave me a copy of
her book the charisma miss and i picked
it up and i couldn't put it down the
book is absolutely fabulous
it has incredibly interesting insights
about charisma and things that are
extremely actionable so she was generous
enough to give her us her time today we
were delighted she's gonna share her
insights on charisma so without further
ado olivia
thank you so much and I'm honored and
flattered to see that it's not just
standing room only but three rows deep
so the pressure is on it was a sunny day
in New York City 1955 the streets flowed
with traffic the sidewalks bustle with
busy people and Marilyn Monroe wanted to
prove a point with a photographer in tow
she walked down into Grand Central
Station though it was the middle of the
week and the platform was packed with
people
not a single person noticed her while
she stood waiting for the Train as the
photographer's camera clicked she
boarded the train and rode along quietly
in a corner of the car nobody recognized
her what Marilyn wanted to show was that
just by deciding to she could be either
glamorous miss Monroe or plain Norma
Jean Baker on the subway she was Norma
Jean but when she resurfaced onto the
busy New York sidewalks she decided to
turn into Marilyn so she looked around
and she teasingly asked a photographer
so do you want to see her V Marilyn and
then he said there were no grand
gestures she just fluffed off her hair
and struck a pose and yet with this
simple shift she suddenly became
magnetic an aura of magic seemed to
ripple out from her and everything
stopped time Stood Still as did the
people around her who stared in
amazement as they suddenly recognized
the star standing in their midst
in an instant Marilyn was engulfed by
fans and it took several
scary moments to help her escape the
growing crowd charisma has always been
an intriguing and controversial topic
and when I tell people that as part of
my leadership work I teach
yzma they often exclaim but I thought it
was something that you're either born
with or not some see it as an unfair
advantage
others are eager to learn but everyone
is fascinated and they are right to be
so charisma gets people to like you
trust you and want to be led by you it
can determine whether you're seen as a
follower or a leader whether or not your
ideas get adopted and how effectively
your projects are implemented like it or
not
charisma can make the world go round
because it makes people want to do what
you want them to do now whenever I'm
asked how I got into this field I have
to admit it was personal desperation and
because by nature I am a socially inept
awkward introvert and by my late teens I
realized that I really only had two
choices either exiled myself to a desert
island or somehow try to make this whole
human thing work so I chose the latter
for now but I'm still keeping the desert
island option open in studying charisma
it turns out that of all the myths
surrounding the subject the most
commonly held was of charisma as an
innate magical personal quality instead
as extensive research has shown charisma
is the result of specific behaviors this
is the reason one of the reasons why
charisma levels fluctuate and as Marilyn
demonstrated it can be there one moment
and gone the next
in fact in controlled laboratory
experiments researchers were able to
raise or lower people's level of
charisma as if they were turning a dial
just by instructing them to display
specific charismatic behaviors charisma
has been turned into an applied science
now one of the reasons why charisma is
mistakenly held to be innate is that
like many other social skills
charismatic behaviors are usually
learned early in life when people don't
even consciously realize they're
learning them they're just trying new
behaviors seeing the results and
refining them eventually the behaviors
become instinctive some people however
make a conscious decision that they're
going to learn this whole charisma thing
Steve Jobs is a great example and if you
go to my blog you'll see a piece called
demystifying the Steve Jobs magic
showing with videos how he consciously
gradually acquired step by step each of
the charismatic behaviors were covering
tonight the blog is called ask Olivia
calm now of course in learning charisma
not everyone is going to come Steve Jobs
nor Bill Clinton for that matter but
everyone can learn enough charisma to
see a measurable difference in their
daily lives so with that said what are
the behaviors that create charisma well
they fall into three categories
behaviors of presence behaviors of power
and behaviors of warmth all three
components of presence power and warmth
are critical to achieve charisma the
only thing that changes is what kind of
charisma you will get depending on which
of these components is strongest so
let's look at each of these components
in turn presence when people describe
their experience of seeing charisma in
action whether they met Colin Powell
Condoleezza Rice or the Dalai Lama they
often mention what an extraordinary
presence the person had
and presence is the single most
requested aspect of charisma when I'm
coaching executives they want to
increase their boardroom presence or
their executive presence and their right
to focus on it because presence turns
out to be the real core of charisma the
foundation upon which all else is built
when you're with the charismatic master
take Bill Clinton for example he gives
you the feeling that he's completely
here with you in the moment present and
I've met hardened Republicans who've
told me Bill Clinton I hated him before
I met him I hated him after I met him
but while I met him man I love the man
have you ever felt in the middle of a
conversation as if only half your mind
were present while the other half was
busy thinking about something else raise
your hands if that's ever happened to
you all right then do you think the
other person noticed when this happens
there's a good chance that your eyes
will glaze over or that your facial
reactions will be a split second delayed
but here's the thing because people can
read facial expressions in as little as
17 milliseconds the person you're
speaking to will likely notice the
smallest delays in your reactions and on
a gut level they'll get the feeling that
something's not quite right something
doesn't quite fit this delay technically
called an in congruence can even give
them the feeling that you are being
inauthentic
nothing ruins
trust or charisma faster than appearing
inauthentic we think we can fake
presence we think we can fake listening
we think that as long as we seem
attentive it's okay to let our minds
turn on other things but we're wrong
when you're not fully present in an
interaction the person you're speaking
to
likely notice it I'm sure you've had
this experience of speaking with someone
who wasn't fully listening you noticed
so how do you get presents well my
favorite technique to stay present a
conversation it's kind of quirky but
remarkably effective so right now if you
would focus on the physical sensations
in your toes your toes big toes little
toes all toes in between however many of
them you have focus on the physical
sensation in your toes what this does is
that it forces your brain to sweep your
body from head - of course toe and gets
you very physically present in the
moment so you do that for only a split
second then you get back to the
conversation but it's very effective
just by focusing on your toes you can up
your level of charisma immediately I
realize that you probably weren't
expecting your toes to be crucial to
charisma they are that's one technique
technique number two is to really focus
on the colors in the eyes of the person
you're speaking with if you pay close
attention you'll see that their eyes
contain a dazzling array of colors that
can keep you quite captivated and better
yet gives you the kind of deep soul
searching eye contact that is extremely
powerful the kind that Bill Clinton is
famous for so obviously don't overdo it
a little goes a long way realize that
giving people your full presence is one
of the most effective ways to make them
feel that they are the center of the
universe and guess what charisma is not
just how you make people feel about you
it's also how you make them feel about
themselves
in the heated London election of 1886
William Gladstone was running against
Benjamin Disraeli for the post of Prime
Minister to the British Empire now this
was a Victorian era so whoever won was
going to rule half the world and in the
very last week before the election
both men happened to take the same young
lady out to dinner on consecutive
evenings naturally the press asked her
what impressions the rivals had made
upon her she said after dining with mr.
Gladstone I thought he was the cleverest
man in England after dining with mr.
Disraeli I thought I was the cleverest
woman in England yes who won the
election it was the man who made others
feel intelligent and fascinating it was
Benjamin Disraeli I often tell my
clients don't try to impress them let
them impress you and they will love you
for it
so that is what charismatic presence can
achieve presidents once again is the
core component of charisma the
foundation upon which all else is built
together with presence power and warmth
combined to create charismatic magnetism
so let's look at power power is not
commanding an army it's not the actual
power you wield it's our perception of
your ability to affect the world around
you whether this be through raw physical
power or large amounts of money
influence expertise intelligence high
social status and so forth we look for
clues of power in the person's
appearance in others reaction to that
person but most of all in the person's
demeanor in their body language
now I'm sure you've all heard of the
importance of body language but listen
to this the MIT Media Lab was able to
predict the outcome of negotiations
sales calls and business plan pitches
with 87% accuracy without listening to a
single word of content only by analyzing
the voice fluctuation and the facial
expression of the person pitching so
what's a powerful body language like
well imagine an alpha gorilla whose
territory has just been breached by a
rival our alpha wants to intimidate the
intruder off his territory what does he
do he beats his chest why why does he
beat his chest to scare the other person
what he's signaling what does beating us
just make him feel strong okay but look
technically from here to here what does
it make him it makes him bigger it turns
out Stanford researchers found alpha
humans do exactly the same thing they
sit on one chair they drape their arm on
a second they put their feet up on a
third or even on the desk
these jesters are all ways of claiming
space if you picture a nervous insecure
person
they're probably claiming a smaller
space than if you picture Colin Powell
so right now if you please put
everything down stand up and give me the
body language of a military general
imagine
imagine that you are a five-star general
and you're reviewing troops of little GI
Joes parading in front of your feet
how would you stand show me all right
white stands excellent thank it makes
you more stable what else would you do
yeah how do you get your shoulders back
you're gonna be there for a couple of
hours better get comfortable how do you
stand relax okay what do you do with
your hands behind your back why do you
put your hands behind your back
it makes your elbows come out it makes
you look bigger puts your your chest
excellent all right now feel how you're
feeling right now when people when
people adopt a these kind of expansive
poses it turns out that they experience
a measurable physiological shift in one
experiments anxiety hormones fell by 19%
while assertiveness and energy boosting
hormones rose by by 25% so when you
assume a physically confident powerful
posture you actually feel more powerful
as you feel more powerful your body
language adapts accordingly this in turn
gives you yet another biochemical boost
and the cycle builds upon itself thank
you very much all you have to do is get
the cycle going
just like an athlete preparing to
perform you're learning how to play
chemist with your own brain and in a way
a lot of the best charisma tools are
learning how to play chemist with your
own brain to get yourself into exactly
the kind of mental state you need for
peak performance and this is of course a
great transition to the mental side of
power so on the mental side what hinders
our power the single biggest obstacle
isn't lack of bank account funds it's
not like if influence and it's not lack
of status symbols the single biggest
obstacle is lack of self confidence in
one of the manifestations of low self
confidence called the impostor syndrome
people feel that they don't really know
what they're doing and it's just a
matter of time before they're found out
and exposed as a fraud this syndrome is
estimated to hit seventy to eighty
percent of the population and it hits
the highest levels of business and
education every time I speak about this
at Harvard at Yale at Stanford at MIT
the room goes so silent you could hear a
pin drop and then the students breathe a
sigh of relief at hearing that this has
a name and they're not the only ones to
have felt it I've heard that every time
the incoming class of Stanford Business
School is asked how many of you in here
feel that you are the one mistake the
admissions committee made
two-thirds of the students immediately
raised their hands dismantling the
imposter syndrome is a three-step
process the first step is d stigmatizing
which means lifting the stigma of shame
off the experience D stigmatizing is
crucial because shame is a real
performance killer of all the emotions
the human being can feel shame is one of
the worst which is widest Ignat izing is
so important and if you are leaders you
have a critical responsibility because
as leaders it's you that people turn to
to understand how they should feel about
their experience as leaders you are by
definition the alphas of your pack
people will turn to you to know how they
should react to events and situations so
you can help them be stigmatized by
understanding this feeling as normal
natural and entirely common
now if DS dignity Singh was step one
detaching is step two
the key to detaching is understanding
that our thoughts are not necessarily
accurate at all just because a thought
is in our head does not mean it has any
validity whatsoever in one well-known
study Harvard researchers asked students
to watch a video in which two teams
played basketball and count the number
of passes made by one of the teams
afterwards the researchers asked the
students did you notice anything unusual
about the video some of you know where
this is going and the students said no
but we can tell you the number of times
they passed the ball what over half the
students had missed is that midway
through the game a woman dressed in a
gorilla suit walked onto the court waved
her arms at the camera and walked off
court again now
if you think you'd do better let's try
something out together right now look
around the room and pick out really
closely everything that is blue really
closely everything that's blue you're
gonna get about 30 seconds to be really
careful all right
close your eyes keeping your eyes closed
keeping your eyes closed could you
please tell me right now everything
that's red thank you how did this happen
because we have a limited capacity for
conscious attention which constrains how
much we can be aware of at any given
moment of the millions of visual inputs
our eyes take in every moment we only
perceive very few the conscious
awareness of absolutely everything
happening around us would be simply
overwhelming so to deal with this our
brain filters for relevant information
either what we specifically asked it to
play to pay attention to red or blue or
what it considers important for our
survival in doing so our mind does not
provide us with a true representation of
reality because it has to filter it
gives us an incomplete view presenting
only some elements and withholding all
others now most of the time the elements
you're missing don't matter and the
picture you get is fairly useful but
sometimes our mind gives us a highly
distorted view of reality that's when
you get distorted thinking and just like
an optical illusion tricks our eyes into
seeing things that aren't real distorted
thinking tricks our mind into being
certain that an inaccurate thought is
true
so that's detaching some cognitive
scientists recommend seeing these
negative thoughts just as we would
graffiti on a wall when you're walking
down a street and you see a graffiti you
might decide that it's an ugly site but
you don't take that to mean that you're
an ugly person when you're meandering
around the maze of your mind if you
encounter an ugly thought try to see it
as just graffiti on a wall detaching was
step 2 of a dismantling process after de
stigmatizing step 3 is learning how to
rewrite reality and since it's actually
a key tool for warmth we're going to see
it under the warmth section warmth
simply put is how much someone gives us
the impression that they like us warmth
tells us whether someone would be
inclined to use whatever power they have
in our favor we perceive warmth almost
entirely through body language and
behavior it's evaluated even more
directly than power the important thing
to know about warmth is that you cannot
fake it because warmth is so closely
tied to body language and there is far
too much body language for us to control
consciously were you aware of your
eyelids fluttering in front of your eyes
right now how about the weight of your
tongue in your mouth how about the
position of your feet have you forgotten
your eyelids again we cannot control our
body language consciously because every
moment there are thousands of units of
information pouring out which is why
great actors were exhausted after great
performances as they were trying so hard
to bring this entire flow into
congruence and even with years of
training it's often impossible to get it
absolutely perfect because if what
you're feeling inside is different from
what you're trying to portray
sooner or later what's called a
microexpression is going to flash and
people will catch that it will give them
on a gut level the feeling of an
incongruent something that doesn't quite
fit maybe something inauthentic so what
did Hollywood do what new form of acting
did they come up with method acting
what's method acting you actually become
the character you want to truly feel
what you want to portray essentially you
don't try to control the output the body
language you go straight to the input
the mind close your eyes for a second
imagine a lemon cut the lemon in half
suck on the lemon juice now imagine
dragging your fingernails across the
chalkboard open your eyes there was no
lemon there was no chalkboard and yet
for many of you it produced very real
physical reactions in response to a
completely imaginary event why did this
happen because our brain cannot tell the
difference between imagination and
reality how many of you have already
been scared watching a scary movie raise
your hand
consciously you knew that it was just a
movie right
you knew that those were just well paid
actors up there who were delighted to
look like they're getting murdered in
exchange for a couple million dollars
but subconsciously your brain sees blood
and guts on the screen it sends you
straight into fight-or-flight mode
adrenaline rushing through your system
in medicine this is called the placebo
effect and you're going to get the
chance to try it out for yourselves so
right now could you please find someone
in the room that you do not like I'm
kidding
turn towards your neighbor finding a
neighbor turn towards them and look
closely at their eyes stay silent look
closely at their eyes
all right when you're ready close your
eyes close your eyes ladies and
gentlemen I want you to think of a
problem at work something annoying
irritating something of which the
outcome is uncertain something
embarrassing something potentially
harmful really get into the feelings of
that problem now open your eyes look at
each other all right close your eyes
what was your eyes again think of
someone you have great affection for
this could be a human being this could
be a pet this could even be a stuffed
animal and try to get really into those
feelings of affection how much they mean
to you and the affection you have for
them feel into the warmth feel into this
tenderness get into these feelings as
much as you can now open your eyes and
look at each other
I promise you'll get a chance to talk to
your new best friends afterwards where
did you see the biggest difference you
saw a difference in their face right
where did you see the biggest difference
the eyes what are the eyes how many of
you are thinking the windows to the soul
absolutely true because the area around
the eyes is the most mobile of the
entire human face and therefore the most
expressive which is why poker players
wear sunglasses and why shipping magnate
aristotle onassis
also used to wear sunglasses when he was
negotiating contracts so that his
opponents could not know what he was
thinking when two human beings look
deeply into one another's eyes what
happens love yes when two human beings
look deeply into one another's eyes
there's an adrenaline like substance
called fini tequila mean rpea
that goes gushing through your
bloodstream and there's it is the same
substance that produces the phenomenon
we call love at first sight you want
that substance in studies we're complete
strangers were asked to stare at each
other after but a few minutes
participants reported increased
affection and some even passionate
feelings for one another
so obviously here also you don't want to
overdo it but it can be very effective
now what are the obstacles to warmth
interestingly they can be the same as
the obstacles to presence or power for
example it's hard to be emitting warmth
when you're in the grip of
self-criticism have you ever been in
conversation when you say something and
you immediately think oh that was a
stupid thing to say what happens to your
face it grimaces what wouldn't what
emotions show on your face all of them
let's get specific when you when you're
thinking oh that was a stupid thing to
say what emotions show on your face
stress shame embarrassment all that
coldness criticism etc yes now this is
self-criticism self-directed tension
coldness or judgment yes but they don't
know that all they know is while you
were looking at them listening to them
and presumably thinking about them they
did see tension kolnas or criticism on
your face so naturally what are they
going to assume that it's about them
think about that the next time that
you're speaking with someone on their
face you see tension criticism or
coolness it might not have anything to
do with you in fact in most cases I'd
say it's self directed never assume your
immediate assumption is the valid one so
once you know that your immediate
assumption is not necessarily valid the
next step is to choose a more charisma
enhancing one this is called rewriting
reality and here's how it works imagine
this it's 8:00 a.m. on a Monday morning
you're driving on the freeway on your
way to a really important meeting
you'll be given a 30-minute presentation
which could change the course of your
career you're focused you're calm you're
ready when all of a sudden a huge black
car
wharves in front of you cuts you off so
with your heart racing and your hands
gripping the stealing you you stomp on
the brake the car keeps swerving in and
out of your lane and finally abruptly
exits the freeway what an idiot
reckless driver now what happened to
your body during this episode a
fight-or-flight response made your
heartbeat accelerate your muscles
tighten and stress hormones flood your
system you know you need to get back
into a charismatic mental and physical
state for your presentation but you only
have a few minutes and you can't get
that incident out of your mind
you could try to suppress the anger but
as Stanford researchers found when
people are asked to suppress negative
emotions their internal experience often
remains unchanged and they sustain
activated elevated activation in their
amygdala in their cardiovascular system
what if instead through a fluke
coincidence
you were to learn that that apparently
idiotic reckless driver was actually a
distraught mother whose baby was choking
in the backseat and it's all she could
do to even keep the car on the highway
while trying to save the baby's life
would that immediately alleviate your
anger for most people it would deciding
to change your belief about what
happened which is technically called
cognitive reframing effectively
decreases this the stress in the brain
in most situations in life you'll never
find out if it was an idiot driver or a
distraught mother so you might as well
choose whichever version of reality puts
you in the most useful mental state so
that's how you remove the obstacles to
warmth how do you actually create warmth
with the exercise that we did earlier
imagine someone for who you have great
affection actually works and thanks a
placebo effect the warmth actually will
be genuine the everything will be
incongruent you're fine however what if
you're dealing with a really difficult
person I'm sure all of you have it
one of them in your lives if not come
talk to me I can lend you a few what do
you do then well a couple of things you
can try first pick three things about
that person that you can approve of I
don't care if it's that they were on
time if they weren't on time at least
they showed up or their shoes were
shined what this does is that it sends
your brain down a certain path which
then of course impacts your body
language next techniques are related to
empathy think about their past their
childhood what was it like growing up in
their family of origin and having their
awkward teenage hood maybe you would
have turned out exactly like them
or as John Bradford put it there but for
the grace of God go I third technique
imagine their present what's happened to
them yesterday or this morning maybe
they're feeling really anxious and if
you're having trouble getting it's an
empathetic state go nuclear I don't care
what you have to imagine whatever is the
worst soon or you could possibly imagine
whether it's their spouse asking them
for divorce that morning whether they've
lost their 2.5 children that day
anything that works the brain does not
know the difference between imagination
and reality so with that said I think
that's just about all we can say about
warmth so to recap once more charisma is
presence power and warmth all three
components are critical to achieve
charisma the only thing that changes is
what kind of charisma you get depending
on which element is strongest
so you'll find the different kinds of
charisma in the book and it will also
run you through which ones are most
appropriate for who you are and what the
situation is but for now would you
please remind me what it is we've
learned today what have you learned
about charisma charisma can be learned
thank you what else just shout it out go
for it be bold
it's hard to fake absolutely what else
it's all about them yes what else sorry
bill Clifton was awesome all right what
else self confidence is crucial yes what
else
presents power and warmth excellent what
else be authentic yes what else play
chemist with your own brain have fun
enjoy what else be empathetic yes give
me a couple of techniques you learned
from today go for it focus on your toes
yes reframe your brain indeed last
couple of ones yes focus on your body
language that would be great idea look
deep into everyone's eyes remember that
don't overdo it part all right last one
charismatic people are great teachers
all right well with that ladies and
gentlemen thank you very much it was a
pleasure
so we have about I think four minutes
for questions so floor is open
I knew Kara's most important is how real
wort works but how do you know that you
are not manipulating authors how did you
know that you're not manipulating others
you are manipulating others charisma is
a tool like any other it's an asset like
any other like intelligence like good
looks like connections like anything
else the cliche I usually give is that a
knife in the hands of a surgeon or in
the hands of a criminal is the same tool
the only thing that matters is your
intent so that I will leave with you
what your intent is good you can do each
day for practice well this gets
interesting get your energy levels up so
play cameras with your own brain workout
in the morning whatever it takes to get
your energy level up to do improv a
she's gonna get really interesting so
here are the three things I often
recommend a client one is improv and
short form improv is one of the best
things you can do for your confidence on
stage your interactions etc - martial
arts so my predilection is Brazilian
jiu-jitsu you want something with real
contact not some sport like
Taekwondo I apologize anyone who is not
in the audience
Brazilian Judas more seriously Brazilian
jiu-jitsu judo something that will teach
you to own the space around you an
alternative is yoga if you if you want
to go that route the third I have
nothing against yoga I'm a big fan of
yoga this Brazilian Jiu Jitsu BJJ
getting your energy up the second was
martial art so improv improvisational
theater my apologies
improvisational theater and the third
would be tango all forms of dance are
excellent ways of getting to own the
stage and learning dynamics tango is
particularly good because it teaches you
the the interaction of the powerplay two
highly charismatic people meet each
other yes it gets really interesting
what you see is with BIA energy levels
go through the roof really the energy
the energy goes on quite a high and I
didn't have time to to cover that today
but there's a whole dark side to
charisma and I'm not talking about the
bad things you can do with charisma
that's obvious I'm talking about the
cost of being charismatic to the
charismatic person charisma can actually
have some highly negative side effects
when you get to highly charismatic
people speaking with another you just
see the scintillating stuffy it looks
pretty it looks great there's a high
energy and everyone gets drunk on that
high yes you know as someone who appears
to be untrustworthy how do you deal with
someone who appears to be untrustworthy
um I'm not sure that I would have a
charisma specific response in this
situation so I guess my best answer
would be I don't know good luck to you
on that one
yes how do you recognize reconcile being
authentic with learning charisma so if
you if you're recalling back to the
exercises we did what we were doing was
not controlling the body language but
controlling your mind yes and what I'm
trying to get you to do is to truly
authentically feel internally the
emotions that you want to portray the
other way that I can tell you is um am I
being inauthentic by speaking English
with you right now
hi exactly English is not my mother
tongue my mother tongue is French
however I'm choosing to use the language
it's going to hopefully get the message
across in the best way
charisma is a language in that same
manner and it's choosing to use the
tools which will make your message most
effective hope this helps yes inside of
the Harvard negotiation project hoping
even the playing field
is acknowledging hoping the
acknowledging openly what the opponent
or your your negotiating partner is
doing so you can if they sit you in a
small chair and put a light on you you
acknowledge them and it shuts down the
effect naming the elephants in the room
so if you if someone's being charismatic
yeah you know they're trying to
manipulate you if you acknowledge name
the charisma that's a brilliant way of
handling it absolutely very good point
so the Harvard negotiation project which
came out with fantastic stuff amongst
which the book difficult conversations
which I highly recommend one of the
outcomes of that was that naming a
dynamic often eases that dynamic and
makes it less powerful so in this case
if you if if you are certain that
someone is intentionally using charisma
to manipulate you naming it can lessen
the situation in the same way
vulnerability can be a wonderful power
tool in creating emotional bonds naming
situation and diffusing it I think we
have time for one more question
one more question whichever it might be
yes
conflict with your portrayal of war can
your powerful presence conflict with
your portrayal of warmth you can
actually portray both of them at the
same time so where it gets really
interesting because a lot of the power
comes through your stance on your
posture and your points so one quick
thing to check if you want to be
emanating power is how much and how
rapidly you are nodding too often people
who are feeling insecure or nervous will
have a lot of self reassuring behaviors
self touching behaviors which are seen
seen by behavioral scientists as low
status individual trying to reassure
high status and they will also be
nodding because they really want to show
you that they're really really listening
to what you're saying so checking that
so it's more about having the the power
in your stature the warmth comes so much
if we're getting specific from your eyes
and your voice that warm eyes warm voice
it doesn't matter how much body powerful
bindings you have it combines very well
did I answer your question yes awesome
thank you
[Applause]
you